the VMAs shadiest moments what you
didn't see on TV plus Taylor's hidden
messages we explain all the shade in her
new video the branches were out at the
VMAs and the temperature throughout the
evening remain chilly with big patches
of shade the ladies of fifth harmony
walked home with a moon man of their own
but they also won me over with their
sexy performance of down and the
foursome made one thing crystal clear
they are just fine without Camila Kibeho
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you see that they literally threw a
fifth member off the stage but it wasn't
just the Camila standing who went flying
host Katy Perry became the moon man
flying down to the stage for her opening
monologue but mere seconds after she
landed Twitter lit up with folks saying
Katy's hosting skills fell flat one of
her biggest critics Adam Levine's wife
Behati Prinsloo who tweeted her jab from
home writing whoever wrote Katy Perry's
script for the VMAs I just want to let
you know it's next-level
cringe-worthy hashtag make it stop and
even Jack Antonoff Taylor Swift's
collaborator and bestie just sat there
eating our friggin banana during her
monologue and you know who else was
surprisingly unimpressed by the jokes
Ellen how hard could it be to impress
the queen of everything nice I'm shook
by this reaction Ellen
[Applause]
now speaking of Katie ears perk up after
Katie made this comment while catching
viewers up who were previously watching
The Game of Thrones finale kendrick
lamar on fire and Sheeran's friends dead
was it in reference to insurance
performance or the fact that old Taylor
Swift is dead
Taylor's words not ours now Swift
herself was not at the VMAs but she let
her presence be known by debuting her
video of latest single look what you
made me do
Katy Perry did not reference introduced
or even show her face when the video
premiered during the show but you know
who was in the audience at the time
ex-boyfriend Calvin Harris check out his
reaction just after the video ended he
sat stone-faced and still and that's
what we call a clap free clap back still
there was no direct reference to Calvin
in the video but Taylor left plenty of
hidden digs for us to uncover in the
first 35 seconds
Taylor is dripped in diamonds in a
bathtub and one might say it's a
reference to Kim Kardashian's Paris
robbery where she was targeted for her
bling and here tailored clearly
channeling Katy Perry with the blunt
haircut and cheetah print but look right
there the Katy look-alike is holding up
a Grammy pointing out that Swift has won
10 and Katy 0 but the rest of the video
Taylor takes aim at her own
headline-making moments
[Music]
she references her cat love itself her
dominatrix inspired bad blood squad any
up that is the I heart TS shirt like we
saw on X Tom Hiddleston but the part
that had me gagging was the girls
straight-up poking fun at her former
selves in this final scene what are you
doing getting receipts I would very much
like to be excluded from this narrative
it is official folks the old and new
t-swift
are never ever getting back together now
I'm sorry if this pop music anarchy is
starting to get too old and too extra
too fast but this is fun I feel like a
detective right but we got to move on to
one of the enemies on Taylor's list Kim
Kardashian Kim was a guest co-host on
live with Kelly and Ryan today filling
in for Kelly Ripa there was no mention
of Taylor's new music video and that's
because Monday's episode was actually
pre-taped but Kim is keeping it real in
this amazing feature in interview
magazine who have declared her America's
new First Lady and they really stuck to
that styling theme Kardashian's dressed
like Jackie O the perfectly tailored
trusses the long gloves big hair come
through 1960s I wanna know what you guys
think I think she totally nailed that
Jackie Kennedy vibes on this one and
look who joined her for the shoot it's
none other than four year old daughter
northwest by her side inside the mag Kim
opens up about her family and her
business she says she feels if all of
this went away she could be a publicist
with how much crisis control she does
for her brood but she also claps back at
the haters who said she had no talent
adding quote you can say a lot of things
about me but you cannot say I don't work
hard I don't sing I don't dance I don't
act but I am not lazy
look she may not be lazy but I need to
know what she thinks of this Taylor
Swift stop give the people what they
want Kim P while I go calm down about
that be sure to hit subscribe and we'll
be back with more and daily denne
tomorrow like come and share and I'll
like comment and dish right back so I
will see you guys tomorrow
oh such good stuff today